[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for what what is it for what what if
what if season 2 episode 8 the most
under promoted Good Thing Marvel has
done ever and I am surprised because it
is it is a great season have you guys
been feeling what do you think about
episode 8 we do not get access to know
what the title is in advance which is
exciting we only have two left so I
think this is 1602 you know I'm going to
do right now I'm going to I'm going to
oh but but in case you do like a big o
face for thumb know that happens to work
yeah we got to block them there we go
now they won't hear me but I'll have a
good expression that's what it counts
man that's a reaction leave a like
people that would be great also
subscribe click the notification Bell to
get notify when our reaction for the
finale is up here on the channel big
thank you to preer for helping us Ed
down this hot lot and full L Reaction
watch along for to sync up with your own
copy of what if that's available for
super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page patreon page M thank you to all who
have joined us so far and John and I
cover several things exclusively with
highlights and watch alongs included
let's watch the pen ultimate ultimate
ultimate ultimate episod episod what if
if we've been filming too many
hours tune in
1602 1602 got to be little flute little
little pipe and flute to be or not to be
Billy shakes that is the question what
tomon to suffer the slings and arrows of
Outrageous Fortune is he doing a play or
to take arms against a sea of troubles
and B my opposing end them he's actually
an a theater actor I love that
Shakespeare is happening to die that is
not
acting is hello on the throne
yes no not again everybody's wanted
Hemsworth and Heston in the same scene
again Happ
true it's
no a rift in time and space 1602 Bal gam
have you read it uhuh it's incredible
that's this Captain you're up no TR
returns this was in the rehears he's
still giving a
monolog oh my God so nice of me to drop
in lucky
you my
queen oh this is going to be awesome
it's
beautiful
oh
hang
on
no sister when him and Hela got along in
one
Universe a Time Stone The Queen Is Gone
technically King Thor Odin son
congratulations Long Live King Thor Nick
Fury bowing to as well oh my God they
all surf your highness I am I'm truly
sorry sorry o my king I am I she is
cursed sees her oh damn do you mind if I
borrow that that's my
yor PO yorck I want her alive
Shakespeare jokes summon the witch I'd
have words about her hero oh was sweet
we saw how that episode ended but I'm
curious how this all started cuz
remember she got pulled in Yeah Yeah by
the witch King marred by loss a soldier
on the Run the World on the brink of
Oblivion cool but how does a Time
displaced super soldier end up with such
a strangely familiar reality the sad
truth is that there are worlds among the
Multiverse so cool simply meant to die
this feels the season feels bigger too
like this is like this has a magnitude
to it oh 1,000% a band of Heroes
gathered together to save their reality
the Scarlet wh Wanda maximoff used her
powers to reach into a neighboring
Universe for a warrior like Captain
Peggy Carter yeah got it the captain
joined the heroes of 16002 in their
desperate bid to save their world what a
crazy timeline this Peggy Carter has
put yes with no way home no place to go
the very rack of Thor I can hear you you
know wait really you
can you're fighting a battle you can't
can't possibly understand two time
periods the 1600s and the early 21st
century have been compressed stuck
together like two pieces of
gum good detail impressive if I don't
find a way to unstick these time periods
this universe will shatter The
overarching Narrative what's that for
I'm going to take you back to your
Universe I'm not leaving worlds die
every day I've watched Millions fade
from existence it happens well not on my
watch going to save million universes
Peg by herself but I still believe she
is the key to our survival for I sense
there is another person from a time that
is still to come poppy calm
yourself Hogan mind your
Affliction a future person more of a
lost traveler a forerunner who has
fallen through time unaware that their
presence is causing our universe to
collapse I like seeing Thor as this
ruler yeah the arrogance is back and the
ignorance and how great H shall we find
this fellow the answer is beyond even my
capabilities sounds like you have your
mission I like how the Scarlet Witch is
actually a witch for the king wit I'm so
happy for Elizabeth
Olsson that's start oh
what what friend of yours more like a
souvenir huh you're right the stuff
gives off an energy probably radioactive
o wait active what now God I love your
madeup words
I need more of this flux capacitor
yes I need more of this I just think the
C the back and forth between everyone is
so much better this time they must have
recorded in the same room can you trace
it in theory yes Magic needed to power
such a device no AR reactors in 1602
again with the beautiful gibberish keep
talking it's like opium to my
ears it's like opium there is one thing
rumored to have enough power to propel a
thousand ships out on New King will let
me borrow his scepter sounds like you
need a thief to help you steal it oo
who's the thief Hulk Hawkeye Hawkeye
makes more sense Hulk Iago I mean
there's some other characters in it but
really the plays about Iago poor U is
such a good joke
they yeah Hawkeye it's like a Robin
Hood he's he's like a Robin Hood and a
period appropriate outfit wait no is
that Captain America your Carriage looks
like it could use some lightning of its
load Rogers hood No Way Outlaw you're
annoyingly chipper they knew what they
were doing yeah they did that both they
knew they pineapple cakes marip that's L
it's actually red we're here for the
coin not the cake Lang now maybe you are
oh there's pie too chag it's very
expensive it's the most expensive
episode of Television yeah this must be
some trickery or a ghost from my made
Margaret pass to the other side many
moons ago I'm dead in this world that's
great sorry I mean that's terrible pgy
she gets to see a buff version of Steve
everybody
wins everybody
wins hi hi I could do this all day have
you guys tried these de claes they're
amazing they blow your mind in every
Universe Paul red has a food thing I
love how we're in England but some of
them are just American just English yeah
in your world is there another Steve
Rogers oh yeah he's a little skinny guy
skinny guy tell me what he's like little
skinny guy no no beard no beard for sure
I don't think I will will you help me I
know I'm not your Peggy but my Margaret
would want to save this world too that
was her
specialty oh my God Peggy do it with him
he's probably a
syphilis statistically what is that oh
no man we've got
company what is happening what oh it's
little yellow jackets oh cool
Royal Yellow Jackets yes Royal Yellow
Jackets the king wants C alive the rest
is up to you I love this so
much oh my God I love this so much
instead of the
arrow can't stand Cofe C don't worry L
you Corner the market on being a pest
they actually have a really good
chemistry of the three of them yeah true
that's
true great this season so good at teams
like assembling teams and Dynamics you
were ingesting about the king hating you
he thinks I killed his sister yeah that
would do it look at him he's the oh
smart yes yes love tracking shots at the
action them sharing the shield just
fills me with such happiness that is so
cool that's AES so
good get it there's some great Shield
choreography this season and then music
that Bucky don't make him mad Would we
not like him when he's mad is he a is he
a B I think we just
won oh the annihilator yeah Destroyer
Destroyer I made it
bigger damn look at this looks like a
Disney animated movie but a good one
like a handdrawn one when they made them
with care and money go find Star I'll be
right behind you I'll draw their fire
and cover your exit men you heard the
lady Retreat this world feels so lived
in and thought out want a whole 602 you
got to read the books think this
true fool hey watch the blood pressure
Hogan oh it's happy Hogan I thought so
earlier the voice but then he got like
Angry in another world we all friends me
you star HT in another world I'm a
compatriot with that madman star well
this is
different I I do need Peggy to sweat a
little bit well yeah we talked about
that in our one yeah yeah just need a
tiny just tiny bit of struggle is that
red School looked like it very brief
though couldn't tell but this is the
ultimate like amalgamation of of what a
what if scenario is even if you find and
destroy this Forerunner what happens
next what if the world doesn't magically
correct itself what if it's the final
straw that destroys this universe what
if what if what if what if what if you
die what if what if what if sounds like
this I have to try the whole what if is
all based in worries what if this some
sort of Suicide Squad and if you're not
going to help me get out of my
way that might be my favorite Captain
Carter outfit this is so
cool great tracking shot holy crap it's
Soldier tastic this is so and super
tight yeah Rogers told me about you the
monster in the iron Mas we could use
your help sh go away yeah but we need
you I don't do that anymore I can't
handle the aggravation it's quiet in the
cell put him as the Man in the Iron Mas
so much peace and quiet stop that
solitary oh yes more Barbarian Hulk give
me that
Savage this might be the visually
prettiest episode to me like the
lighting here these costumes
Hulk Hulk with the beard
Maestro run
under riding him
yes
wow
Hulk By Night Loy people wrong I know
buddy Peggy will fix it I
hope painting gorgeous painting here
Banner this will set you straight and
nude I like how there are Rifts on like
The Avengers movie like the first one
like a receptor and everything which led
me to finishing my greatest invention
ever ignore that it's
decorative your stunned silence is
flattering though I'm not opposed to
Applause this love is like not a
respected mad sizes oh like love me it
will reveal the Forerunner and send them
back from whence they came once you know
the prized Royal stone is inserted storm
of the castle got of our thing Steve
well lady sorry we're late got her
Shield back wrestle this from some
Palace guards on the way over I thought
you might need it touching would have
gone with a Sonet personally you guys
are so cute
during the upcoming court session we'll
enter in Disguise Lords and Ladies from
across the kingdom will be there so will
the Forerunner Tony will line wait with
a device we get the stone and save the
world they're doing like several
Avengers movies he's a CL man and he's a
military man and he um it's an annoying
actor I love Tom hson just having joy as
ass in my ear one more time why do you
hate music so much why do you hate music
so much
it's a great Easter egg St is upon
us now or never what's the signal it's
interesting to see Thor portrayed most
like Odin yeah signal
signal come on Buck together we'll teach
them to dance
Ma
damn the way they have re visioned Bucky
is perfect man I love to swash
[Music]
buckle Loki let us join the fry brother
where's the hammer I got you I have
misplaced
it my king we are short on time coming
through make a hole hey I'm walking
[Music]
here per God I want this Hulk back taste
my steel you vile truy
onioning my your face revokes me I like
he was actually good with a
sword sir Hogan I am so
sorry great job Rogers you made him mad
good luck is he like an Abomination oh
there's the purple version too he's got
it here too somehow he's a Hulk
that's cool to tie it in yeah I don't
know how but it's great fetch me the old
father it's vibranium coronation gift
from the king of
wakanda Steve we have
trouble got a little trouble of my own
Rifts in space relating to the live
action oh it' be great wouldn't it this
is quite a you got there th please
we can stop this oh Father give me
strength you're more of a drama queen
than your brother
[Laughter]
[Applause]
bless easy I I I could get you a new
feather oh there we go
yeah hul smash thee Hulk smash
thee oh my
God
[Music]
this cool yeah
okay and is given just as much respect
as he was
in woo
[Music]
woo great fight fights both fights are
all the fights happen are great next
time no Hulk who I
Surrender now only Tony can get in the
[Music]
fight I've got enough of your
devilry interesting to have a weapon
that combines with his thunderous
abilities weapon yeah what I'm sorry so
medieval epic we're out of time Fury
what are you doing find me an opening
treason get the to St here we go what a
finale yeah we still have one
more you got to be kidding me St it's
only a failure if it
explodes come
on pegy
now what does she have to do oh is it
going to be the Iron Man suit from Iron
Man suit to like cover her oh she got
gauntlets oh
yeah
whoa
what did it's him
him the
Forerunner he's the future man that's
impossible I remember a battle we were
fighting a monster from the skies armed
with a Golden Glove no went to strike
with hit one of the stones instead oh
it's still alternate version okay it's
true Carter was right
I thought it was going to be him going
back giving the stones through time and
I was like are we about to get a Canon
event like Carter don't be a fool finish
your task the one you were summoned for
py oh is me any experienced Amnesia we
both know what I need to do and have
seia my lady oh they always have to say
goodbye o every Universe except for one
after a while we never get our happy
ending you do once I'm sure somewhere
out there we do a oh he does it oh dud
this season is so good I like really
felt that dad that was incredible
damn that victory was its own sort of
curse because every battle you won would
mean you're only getting further from
home yeah yeah it's not really a
Superstition come here to gloat tell me
that I'm stuck here forever is it
strange no I just thought you could use
a friend
yeah what are you doing here oh have I
got a story to tell
you I love how he's just been continuing
on yeah part one for the finale favorite
episode that's favorite new favorite how
was everything I wanted what is this
season I like want to like I wish there
was like a Mr Marvel I be like Marvel
this is what you should be promoting I
know my God God guys why haven't you
bought a shirt yet I don't get it Coy
similarly vexing at reation shop.com you
can get shirts like this one you see on
screen and this one too and then this
one as well and also this one which I
enjoy and there's another one and
there's so much more it's like the best
way to support the channel we love they
were part of how they exist and it's
also you know we're creatively involved
we got more to Comon did you get money
for the holidays spend it there anyway
cool let's talk about this but episode
like that was crazy like that was so
many like what what do what do what do
you want this is going to sound
strange this has weirdly been the show
that has massively regained my faith in
Marvel I was thinking not just that
because I agree but I was also thinking
this is not this just the show that's
getting me back into the like Avengers
scope team up organizized organizized
organized but also it made me realize
how much I miss certain things I miss
Savage Hulk I miss the dynamic feeling
like it's already established not like
they're trying to build out I miss
things feeling less chaotic Ironically
in a chaotic show called what if like
it's doing all of the things that I
forgot like when you rewatch something
you can never experience it for the
first time again this feels like I'm
experiencing old Marvel for the first
time again yes let me elaborate because
like do I think the show is better than
Loki season 2 no I don't no I don't
think it's but does it feel more like a
traditional Marvel thing in a great way
I think what they have done is the thing
is with Loki season 2 they're telling
one story right Guardians 3 they're
telling one story and in our story Coy
loves to play with his mic when Greg's
talking it's great it's his favorite
it's a great habit he's in my head it's
a visual thing but it's obviously an
auditory thing but it's but my brain
doesn't compute that there is that what
you
think
yes it's not a flute C it is H his
microphone that's your thumb where's
your stray jacket
ah
anyway they are doing a variety of
different stories and on top of that too
it is a SE a sophomore season to a
season that left a lot of people feeling
like it's fine I know people skipping
this season because of how season one
made them feel if this was season 1 then
I would put what if in my top third of
Marvel my point is they knew how to
improve they knew how to take something
improve it they have brought us a
variety of different stories they have
showed us like no we really do know
these characters and love them and
that's why because this is embracing the
whole MCU this season and like lowkey
season 2 was phenomenal and my favorite
of the Marvel stuff so far this year
however this is this is a completely
different type of thing from Loki but
also kind of similar because Multiverse
whatever but do you get my point of why
why I would say like like Loki I'm like
yeah Loki's kind of like this isolated
story I love Loki versus love the I love
that that story they're telling this is
MCU you know right Loki's got more in
common with like your sci-fi Doctor Who
stuff whereas this feels like the MCU
yeah which I which I had missed yeah and
that's why and and an episode like this
which is an Avengers tale like one of my
favorite is a very different comic I
haven't read 1602 comic um but one of my
favorite Comics I read when I was a kid
was Batman thrill killer have you read
that um where it's like Batman in the '
50s or 40s something like that where and
it's some type of idea where you take
these characters and you put them it's
like a Gotham by gam slam kind of thing
yeah and um and so I always love those
ideas and I and I really think they
brought that to life here in a very very
strong way I think it's excellent like
the the way they swapped out every
character here with where you even even
though Steve is connected to modern day
there were like Clues like hey his
appearance his buff and he's got the
shield yeah the shield was like the
biggest giveaway they kept using it I
kept being like I should feel suspicious
and I wasn't I was just like but where
they put um you know Bucky the kind of
role he served Hogan the deliciousness
of Paul rud's comedy yeah Paul rut's
comedy um and but even when happy Hogan
to be like that sniveling servant yes
and another Hulk Hogan but like of
course because of that many variations
there might be another universe that has
him get those Powers I loved that Banner
as the as the man of the Iron Mask lro
Banner brilliant play Oh everyone oh
freaking Tony Stark as like the mad
scientist who's like not really
respected I should not have laughed that
hard at Hulk smash the like that was so
much joy smash that was like pure and
did know Mark Ruffo got to say that in a
booth like just me picturing how happy
Mark Ruffo must be to like get to do
this Hulk again Scarlet Witch man and
like Elizabeth Olsen getting to be a
witch getting to be the actual witch who
serves and this writer you know probably
watched ju division so I really enjoyed
her getting to be the character that she
wants to play I really think that what
they did here was excellent and
every so many episodes this season and
and especially this one have left me
feeling like I wish we could watch a
whole series out of these characters out
of this like they announced they wanted
to do Marvel zombies um I would much
rather see Marvel 1602 I would much
rather see Marvel also they they
confirmed season three of this at the at
the event they whatever that small event
yeah I hope it's as good as this cuz
this is exceptional this is making me
want a lot more Marvel whereas lately
Marvel's I've been like you know slowing
Down's not the worst yeah like you know
what I mean next year we get we get
Deadpool as the only live action but
next year we also get three animated
series and like if they're as good as
this holy crap and the mirror
reflectiveness that they were doing
between Peggy and Steve throughout when
they both get to be the prime like you
know enhanced super soldier serum
versions of themselves where Peggy went
down the same path as uh as Captain
America and you're watching them
interact with each other and the
choreography that was when her Soldier
mirroring and then all the Avengers
stuff and Shakes Loki oh my God the
poror line was such a deep cut well not
that deep but it's like a medium cut
Shakespeare like film student joke that
was such a good joke I this is my
favorite episode like this is what I
love about the Avengers this is what I
love about wha ifs this is what I love
about the cast because they got to play
at like this level together this is what
I love about the power of Animation
because 1602 might have looked silly
with actors in it this is all of the
reasons to make a wh if in one episode
and uh this is also a comic that I love
dearly the 1602 Neil game and run is is
I I I hold it near and dear to my heart
so this being adapted this beautifully
was so fun this was great they all have
like personalities my least favorite
episode this season is still better than
most of last season oh absolutely two
yeah yeah still I think a lot of people
really like that one um I don't know
it's still on for me that's the only one
I'm like kind of on the bottom of it's
not not bad it's just I think it's the
only one that didn't stick The Landing
all of but the problems that I have with
that one could have hap could have
occurred here with oh look at these
different Avengers roster characters all
showing up in this big Ensemble episode
but every everyone here even if they
they even if they don't have a lot of
screen time they had like at least
something that allowed them to really
shine in one moment right you know and I
think the mix and matching of everyone
was excellent and so I I unlike that
episode where I was like oh cool we got
this guy this guy this guy didn't do
much yeah they didn't feel utilized this
they felt utilized everyone was properly
utilized and uh guys I got a little bit
of brainwave power left in me my voice I
have been fighting everything in me to
not sound like I'm coming down for the
sore because certainly
am a lot of talking yesterday I can't do
I can't do what you do qu it's not easy
and I don't know how but I lose it and I
get really sick this is the first year
since you've known me that I haven't
gotten sick in DEC I've been taking so
much vitamin C it is the only thing
combating this right now last year I
almost went deaf permanently and the
year before that I got covid the year
before that I had a flu I as long as
I've known you this time of year I'm
usually clinging to life so uh we've
both been working on taking care of
ourselves obnoxious amount of
antioxidants we've got one more episode
left one more episode
we and then I'm going to go work on
video then you're going to edit silence
don't worry don't worry people that
think Greg doesn't do enough he's still
working don't worry I got it guys he's
just doing it in silence this is this is
the you guys going to see the fun part
yeah don't you worry while you're
resting at home we're filming and
editing yeah you guys get the fun side
rela and then I'll do the other stuff
tomorrow fin what is happened it's like
a demon outside I was like a loud
squeaky demon we'll see you tomorrow see
you tomorrow finale much love happy New
[Music]
Year